to stress that you do have to
participate in some discussion session
and it's also wise to participate in
some discussion session because the
teaching assistants will be grading
except for the graduate students in my
section and therefore it's best to no
get to know them what kind of scotch
they like as a gift
whatever blandishments you're accustomed
to showering upon the people who
determine your fate I was talking at the
end of class on Tuesday about the what
appears to so many historians and
archaeologists to be a kind of a paradox
that in the New World you have figurines
with wheels but you don't have any any
wheeled vehicles to me that is not in
particular a paradox but it seems to
defy common sense now there's one way to
look at it that's purely technical and
that is to look at the experience that
Galileo had when he was dealing with the
question of if you make a model of
something that it works and then you
scale it up you know you have this beam
instead of being six inches long you
make it six feet long and so forth then
the whole thing falls apart and he
recognized and this is partly from
visits to the arsenal' in Venice that
scale is something that is
a matter of indifference to a geometers
but a matter of crucial importance to a
to a person who's actually working with
materials because you have to calculate
in stresses and strengths and it's a
very very complicated task you know if
you know Archimedes if he'd have a lever
that was long enough and a fulcrum would
have had a broken lever because these I
can move the world with the lever that
long unless it's made of you know
adamantium or some other well-known
unbreakable metal so with wheels you
have very much a technical issue the
wheel is held forth as the paradigmatic
self-evidently good invention and to the
point that the notion of reinventing the
wheel is taken as a cliche for for doing
something that doesn't need to be done
more than once it's already been done
thank you
however the question of the wheel is
complicated first of all what was the
first wheel like now here we have we
confront two types of evidence one type
of evidence comes from Mesopotamia and
it takes the form of basically that
geometers notion they're little
pictographs
so we have a little house and then you
know pictograph that shows it on runners
on a sledge or a sled and then a
pictograph I chose that and that is
taken to be the earliest evidence for
wheeled transport in Mesopotamia
virtually simultaneous with that
according to carbon-14 dating and it was
very different type of dating because
the best premium stuff tends to be hard
numbers related to the reigns of Kings
whose rains are known whereas carbon-14
dating is is based purely on a
scientific calculation but the earliest
known actual wheels come from Denmark at
almost exactly the same time as the ones
in Iraq and there's a long way between
Denmark and Iraq this has given rise to
a sometimes heated argument among
archaeologists as to where the wheel was
invented was it invented in northern
Europe or was it invented in the Middle
East it was invented in the Middle East
if it appears in a society that is a
grain growing agricultural society that
already has cities already has a fairly
sophisticated technological toolkit and
as a writing system because the same
images that that we see there are
matched by other graphemes that better
related to the origins of writing and
roughly is around 3,500 BC
I say roughly because your first
evidence of something isn't necessarily
terribly close to the beginning of
something the Danish wheels the northern
European wheels instead of having an
image of them we have the actual wheel
preserved in peat bogs essentially that
lack any oxygen that could have that
would have caused the the organic
material in the wheel to deteriorate so
what we have is a piece of wood solid
piece of wood we have a whole the center
of the piece of wood and if you look at
the at the profile of a piece of wood
let's say there's the width of the wheel
it looks
like fast in other words the whole the
part that has the hole in it is drawn
out on either side if you have ever done
something like trying to fix a weight to
a lifting bar one of the things you know
is that if it will slide onto the bar
it will also wobble and so you put on a
sleeve that you type in in order to hold
it in place or find other some other way
to hold it in place because the problem
is that if you have enough enough leeway
for the wheel to go onto a rod that is
your axle you're going to have a wobble
factor the way you defeat the wobble
factor is by having the area through
which the actual passes be very wide
because the wider it gets the if you
don't make it tighter but by making it
wider it means that the leeway for
wobble diminishes so this this area in
here part that sticks out is known as
the knave
the earliest wheels that these 3,500 are
fifty-five hundred year old wheels from
3500 BC were chipped out of solid wood
with probably with stone implements
that's a lot of chipping of course
depending upon the size so part of the
question is what is the diameter of the
wheel and here you have a one of these
technical things of the sort that that
are not obvious from a model that little
you know toy Jaguar with a with wheels
on it in Mexico could not have gone on
any surface other than something really
flat because if you have a very small
wheel it doesn't take much of a of a
barrier or step or something to keep it
from moving ahead you need a flat
surface on the other hand flat surfaces
road road surfaces let's say require a
great deal of effort to prepare so if
you're if you're thinking about making
wheel do you make a road first yeah
we're going to invent the wheel next
week but today we're going to make you
know seven miles of flat road no you
don't yes we assume that the first
wheels went over uneven ground and this
necessitated a substantial diameter
because it had to be able to roll over
bumps so the diameter is roughly three
feet
okay now bat if it is out of a single
piece of wood it means that you have to
have a tree that is at least 3 feet in
diameter otherwise how are you going to
to get something round out of a single
piece of wood well certainly iraq didn't
have any trees 3 to 3 feet diameter iraq
head scarcely any trees at all other
than other than date palms and they
palms don't grow like like other trees
they're actually more like stems and
they don't have the physical properties
to to return in two wheels effectively
so you know you wonder what they had in
iraq but they probably didn't have three
foot in diameter oak trees they lived
they would have the way they would have
had in northern europe now you can
simply take three planks and put them
next to each other and fasten them with
pegs and and fish glue or something and
make something that will be three feet
that will sustain a three-foot feet
three foot diameter wheel but and we and
we have later evidence of this so-called
tripartite wheel but the first ones were
simply made out of solid wood and if you
think of at the original piece of wood
had to be like that you realize that
somebody spent weeks chipping away wood
in order to get to a wheel this was
enormous ly labor-intensive to make that
wheel and when you got down to it you
had a you did have a wheel but you had a
very heavy wheel if you take the density
of oak and you'll calculate the size of
the wheel and you had my my calculation
is that you must have had a wheel that
weighed roughly 60 pounds now 6-0 now if
you have four wheels we're talking about
240 pounds of wheel you add the weight
of the axle or if two axles if you have
four four wheels then you add the weight
of the whatever it is that holds the
whole thing together the structure of
the vehicle and we're up to you know 300
400 pounds of vehicle now the problem is
that the power available from a pair of
oxen is a fixed amount it's a fixed
power input oxen remain roughly the same
strength from ancient times through
medieval times down to early modern
times so you have a fixed
power source a pair of oxen and you have
the capability of those oxen carrying
loads on their backs and in certain
parts of the world pack cattle are
terribly important let's say the entire
economy of Tibet relates to a species of
oak ow namely the Yak carrying goods
around on its back now you can cross a
yak with a cow and you get as Oh so when
you see masses of yaks and pictures from
Tibet you have to ask yourself am I
looking at yaks or it zoe's and then you
think you're in the middle of a dr.
Seuss book and you know it's the Zoe's
and the snows versus the yaks and the
cracks or something but but you can
actually tell supposedly there are two
ways I've never tried to check it out
one is that the tale of a yak hat is
like the tail of a horse has long silky
strands and therefore yak tails are used
as fly whisks in as a luxury consumption
item in Indian history but the tale of
adds oh is like the tail of a cow it's a
long rope with a little tuft at the end
on the other hand the whole thing is
covered so much hair you can't really
see the tail very much the other thing
is and I just rely on inform us for this
that yaks won't walk in a straight line
that yaks are like sheep they they like
to to be beside each other it's sort of
one bundle together whereas those will
line up and you can have them in the
caravan I'm not sure quite how they get
it o get yaks through Himalayan passes
in
blood shows but maybe they can so you
could have you could have Pat cattle so
the question is how much can you carry
on an ox versus how much can the ox pull
and of course the wheeled vehicle
increases what it can pull because
you're you know you're you are selling
is rolling well the other hand the
weight of the vehicle itself is so great
so it seems fairly clear that there was
no economic use for the earliest wheels
that the the effort to build it did not
offer enough of an increment defending
over the weight that could be carried by
the same animals to make it ad
economically useful invention
particularly when you take a new to
account the fact that oxen carrying
loads in their backs can pick their way
over rough country you don't have to
worry about the surface whereas as soon
as yoke wheels you have to worry about
you have to worry about the surface now
the wheel evolves from this beginning
driven by a a very clear technological
demand to make it lighter to make the
wheel lighter and lighter and lighter
now for this most primitive type there
are two possible ways to make it lighter
both of which show up although we don't
have clearly fixed dates on them one of
them is two is not is that
is to fix the wheel to the axle so it
doesn't turn in other words to take two
wheels axle between them and the whole
unit turns so then you don't worry about
a wobble you can nail the damn thing to
the axle or fix it however way you can
it's a fixed a fixed unit and you might
think well I've never heard of that
being done alone
children's toys have said all the time
but but in fact if you go to Turkey
today and look at surviving ox carts
from the early 20th century you'll find
that one of the most common designs is
to have the two wheels nailed to the
axle and then the whole unit terms
instead of each wheel turning at the end
of the axle now that reduces the weight
because you don't have to have you don't
have to have a name you can tell in a
picture whether you are looking at a
wheel that is fixed or if wheel that is
rotating you can tell by looking at this
if it is round then the wheel is
rotating but if it is square then the
wheel is not rotating so you know you
look at a picture of some ancient scene
and you end and you can tell that was
one way to do it but it was not the
preferred way to do it it doesn't appear
because square holes do not show up all
that often in in early depictions the
other way to do it was to take the nave
and make it a separate piece of wood so
then what you're doing is you're taking
your big piece of wood and you're
cutting a big hole in the center and
then you're inserting in that big hole
a separate piece of wood that's the day
that comes out on both sides you can
also of course then have different types
of wood you can have a harder wood
perhaps for the knave heavier wood and a
lighter wood for the wheel itself and so
we have specimens of inserted names
nevertheless there's sort of a limit to
how far you can go with that when once
you've tried that idea so
my mother was a physics professor and
she taught me that if you're at a
blackboard and you want to draw a round
circle and you're right-handed draw it
counterclockwise if you do it clockwise
it will be it won't look right but if
you drop counter clockwise it will be
pretty round so if you learn nothing
else out of this part someday when
you're in a meeting making sense or
presentation you'll put this impressive
round circle on the you know on the
whiteboard or wherever and you'll think
of me and I'll be so proud now yeah now
the quest to make it let's say you have
a an inserted naves over a large hole
here how do you make this lighter well
you get rid of the wood after all you
need would know at the axle you know at
the point where the accident goes
through you need wood where the rubber
hits the road but you don't need all
that wood in between so people started
to cut out chunks of wood and a cut out
chunks of wood
so they saved a lot of wood and lo and
behold and invented the spoke because
once they discovered that you could
lighten the wheel by cutting out the
wood then they thought well actually you
don't need one big piece of wood at all
all you need is the center part of that
contacts the axle and an outer part that
contacts the road surface and you can
simply use rods to connect the two
technologically this is an enormous
advance in manufacturing terms it is a
huge problem
any farmer could make a solid wheeled ox
cart and if you look at the ox carts of
turkey in the early 20th century they
still have solid wheels says the spoke
did not drive the heavier solid wheel
out of existence although they did start
to taper the wheel so the solid wheel
would have be smaller that side where it
hits the road than it was in the center
so there's some improvements in the
solid wheel but but basically the
problem with the axle are with the if a
spoke was that it was very very
difficult to do it also raised a
question of what is this outer rim does
it mean you have to to have a wooden
hula hoop or something do you have to
have a single hoop of of wood which
could be complicated particularly with a
large diameter and so I said well no you
can make this out of segments
so it's one segment shoe segments and
then you could use pegs to pass in the
segments together and then you'd have a
certain fixed number of spokes for each
segment to help hold it in place and
these segments these segments were
called fellas
why it's pronounced Feli when it looks
like it's fellow I don't know
so the wheel came to be made of bellies
spokes and nave with an axle going
through the center
once you figure out how to do this the
number of spokes becomes becomes a
variable so that in the earliest Chinese
chariots you're dealing with you know
say 45 spokes you deal with Roman racing
chariots may of dealing with six folks
and part of that has to do with with how
many pieces how many of the fellows
there are and with what is the overall
diameter if you are racing chariots you
want to have the lightest wheels and the
lightest wheels ultimately are still the
ones with the smallest diameter so
chariot races used chariots with
comparatively small wheels not that you
ever see that in movies where I must say
the most primitive technologies are
invented by movie designers that they're
no relation to reality so chariot racers
might use low diameter small diameter
wheels as you see on Roman depictions
but a large diameter wheel meant a big
guy a powerful person in other words
there was a prestige having to do with
you know my wheel is bigger than your
wheel it's a guy thing
the there are from from Shang China
which you've read about this week
there's seven chariots that have been
excavated from Shang period sites and
there
two of them had the wheels and the
others the wheels have been dismounted
and we're somewhere else were not found
but in the two where they had the wheels
the diameters were close to five feet no
yes close to five feet about 57 inches
those are big wheels and there are other
excavations in Central Asia that show
wheels of comparable size and with
zillions of spokes and these show up in
tombs because if you have a really
really fine ride you want it to be
buried with you so so chariot burials
for a period of several hundred years
become very important in the history of
of Eurasia from northern China all the
way across to to Eastern Europe we have
several hundred chariot burials
sometimes with the skeletons and horses
there to show the horses were killed and
put in the grave along with the chariot
sometimes with the chariot disassembled
sometimes with it intact but all of
these are identified by archeologists as
being very high-status individuals the
later on the northern European version
of this was to be burned in your vote in
your boat your Viking or if you are come
to the good Redeemer and section of
foggers Ring cycle you get a nice biking
vote burning but the suggestion here is
that there was a very strong association
of wheeled vehicles with prestige
now why would that be the case because
after all what you're starting with is
something that's really clunky we know
that it had a very a I was only talking
about weight of the wheel well we know
that there was very strong friction
getting getting a 60 pound wheel to turn
on a wooden axle sure you can put in
bear grease or whatever and we actually
have one example of prehistoric wheels
for northern Europe that apparently used
roller bearings there were little
grooves carved out where you could
insert you know hardwood pegs to help
the wheel turn but by and large you have
a lot of friction and those oxen had to
overcome the friction and they had to
pull the weight and the friction wasn't
only the friction of turning on the axle
what is the friction of the the the
wheels against the ground you don't know
ice think of this but the point of
contact between that we on the ground is
a very important source of a friction
it's the reason railroads are the
cheapest form of wheel transport is
because a hard steel wheel against a
hard steel rail has all you know unlike
something else where where the wheel is
actually climbing up a little incline in
order to start there there's no
depression of the rail by the by the
train wheel and therefore you have a
minimum of friction and give you
references on that bicycle technicians
have worked very very aggressively on
the issue of friction of bicycle wheels
for competitive purposes
so you have pictured the reason you
don't have wheelbarrows at the beginning
is because the friction is too great the
muscle power it takes to operate one
wheel is greater than a than a grown man
can can exert that's the indicator of of
the role of friction here now it's also
important to to realize that if you have
four wheels that is to say if you have
two axles and two wheels on each axle
until four wheels I probably could have
figured out how they be organized
without my saying that if you have four
wheels two axles the friction is doubled
now you have a fixed power source of a
pair of oxen and you have a choice of
having one axle that has a lot of
friction or two axles that will double
the amount of friction so the logical
thing is that you don't you have four
wheels the logical thing is that you
have two wheels everyone in the world
over time figured that out except the
Europeans
for images or actual manifestations
surviving remnants of four wheeled
vehicles show up in European situations
from let's say from 3000 BC till today
the Europeans have this attachment to
four wheels they also use two wheels by
no means a you know a single-minded
thing but they have four wheels and who
else no four wheeled vehicles in China
no four wheeled vehicles in India
nope four wheeled vehicles in most of
the colonial lands unless it's a
carriage for the for the Viceroy but in
Europe four wheeled vehicles along with
two hill vehicles you think here are the
people who invented the wheel which was
a pretty stupid invention and then they
compounded it by using it in the
stupidest form that anybody could think
of why would they do that what is the
what's the value added of having four
wheels and of course when I ask people
this if if I allow them to answer they
say well you can put more in it yes you
can you can have a longer wagon vent you
can put more in it but it doesn't make
your accent any stronger your oxen can
pull a greater weight with a two-wheeled
vehicle then it then they can pull with
a four-wheel vehicle so having a bigger
size doesn't it's a delusion that that
that is a gain in efficiency on the
other hand there are certain things that
you don't want to tip over and this
course is a problem two-wheeled vehicle
is that it it can be tippy
what don't you want to turn over you
don't want the statue of the goddess to
fall off the cart onto the ground you
don't want the great urn carrying the
ashes of the King to fall off the cart
and break on the ground and you can make
an argument both in logical terms and in
visual terms from surviving images that
a substantial proportion of the four
wheeled vehicles were used in religious
processions where economic efficiency
was utterly irrelevant and also where
the distance traveled was very short and
therefore you could make a smooth road
surface if you're just pulling the
vehicle from the temple out to the
public square and then back to the
temple again you can make that you can
make that pretty smooth let's say in
India where the only vehicles used
historically for thousands of years were
two-wheeled vehicles an exception was
made for for two things one was made for
images supposedly depicting warriors in
the great bharata war
so later indian images of chariots show
someone in a chariot with four wheels
but that someone is usually looks like a
statue of a god and the other thing is
that you could actually take an entire
temple and put it on wheels and this is
what is known as the juggernaut in
eastern india there is a religious
center where every year a huge
a temple like structure is placed on
wheels and it's pushed along a
ceremonial way it's called a juggernaut
in American you know American usage of
the term which of course is immortalized
in x-men you know the last stand but the
juggernaut was so heavy and so
inexorable it is motion forward that if
you slipped and fell you would be
crushed by the juggernaut because the
juggernaut would crush everything now if
you go now and look for images of the
juggernaut online one of the things you
find out is has 18 wheels because how
else are you going to carry something
that's the big of that much weight and
then you think oh it's making wheeler
you think no it's not because there are
no none of them are on the same axle
instead you have 18 individually
suspended wheels put it various places
underneath and it's pushed by people
it's not pulled by animals it's kind of
neat um alright so you can use your
wheeled vehicle ceremonially I think
that in Iraq what that is that little
bitty house that shows up in the
ideogram I think that that is a shrine
and that when you see sometimes a person
in the house
that that's a statue and that the
ceremonial function of wheels was a very
important component in their development
and in the press for continual
improvement of the of the technology not
able to prove that but that is why
that's my suspicion when you go to a
slightly later time medieval Europe even
early medieval Europe in fact going back
to the late Roman Empire and you look at
you collect images of four wheeled
vehicles you find that those that are
pulled by animals because there are some
that are being manhandled by teams of
men but those are pulled by animals are
passenger vehicles for multiple
passengers and the passengers are women
is one of the most peculiar areas of
gendered history if you have a high
status woman anywhere in the world how
do you move her from place to place it
is a big problem if you have a chariot
of course she can be there next to the
chariot driver but if you're her husband
and you're not driving the chariot and
she goes off with the no that's not good
at that that can't be good
you can put her in a sedan chair and
carry her and this was done in certain
societies indeed the Emperor of Japan
down through the Meiji period in the
19th century always travelled by sedan
chair you know throughout Japan he was
just carried everywhere he went
so you can use a sedan chair but then
she's all alone and so you have to have
a bodyguard and so forth and so on
in some society she can ride a horse
ultimately in Central Asia women ride
horses in northwest Europe women ride
horses
sidesaddle usually because you have the
costume difficulty or you have another
choice which is to leave the woman home
so that there's a correlation between
societies that that leave women at home
high status women that seclude high
status women and societies that don't
have the means to move them around in a
fashion that will protect their personal
safety on their modesty when you read
the history of Islam you'll find that
the the question of modesty for the wife
of Muhammad who is traveling in a closed
saddle on top of the camel that got
separated from a caravan it's one of
most crucial issues in Islamic history
you know a woman a high-status woman by
herself is if not in danger is her
husband can be victimized as a you know
and shamed by the whole thing
so the solution if you have a four-wheel
vehicle is to have a whole party of
women moving the princess and her
ladies-in-waiting and they move together
we have many many depictions of this and
they're all from Europe and almost all
from Eastern Europe many of them from
from the ottoman period in you know
where parties of women would go to on
picnics out of outside of Istanbul but
you have them from other parts of Europe
as well now this is important because in
Eastern Europe you have the invention of
the carriage of the coach rather coach
is a Hungarian word and it appears that
that is where the coach originated what
is a coach you're familiar I would
imagine in the design of a modern
automobile we have a chassis and a body
the chassis consists of the basic frame
of the motor the wheels the transmission
system all the guts of the on the
automobile and then on top of it you
place the body which is separately
manufactured and it can be
interchangeable you can have the same
chassis for a Pontiac irnos mobile or a
Cadillac something like that you just
change the body well that that was one
of the aspects of a coach was that the
body was separate it was separated from
from the chassis why did that happen it
was because of the invention of
suspension you could have a you know
when suspension is invented
let's say that the most earliest forms
you know for wheeled vehicle with
verticals in either end to hook on the
verticals and a hammock slung from the
hooks we actually have both a
description from in Arabic but written
by a in Arabic by an ambassador from
Spain that describes us in precise
detail and we have a medieval miniature
showing a vehicle exactly like this
where somebody is riding and they
hammock suspended from hooks the coach
took this notion of suspension and they
said well let's take leather straps or
chains and suspend them from the front
for the hooks and then we'll take a body
and lower it on top so it can sway and
you don't get troubled by the bounces
well warriors don't worry about being
troubled by the bounces but the princess
with her delicate sensibilities and her
ladies waiting they want a better ride
so I think that the development of
suspension is related to the transport
of high status women in Eastern Europe
in in wheeled vehicles there are other
aspects of this that I will get to in a
later lecture on Europe I just want to
point out that it's only in Europe that
you get this obsession with the
with the four-wheel vehicle you get the
invention of suspension you will get the
invention of steering which I'm not
going to go into right now get the
invention of brakes all of which arise
of four wheeled vehicles and what you
you end up with is that in the steam era
the only part of the world that has the
technological expertise to have power
driven wheeled transport as Europe
that's where the trains the cars and so
forth originate because they've already
solved the problems of brakes and
steering suspension for wheels so forth
and so on you take you take away your
your team of oxen and you replace it
with an an on board of steam or later
internal combustion engine and now you
have a modern vehicle now if I insert an
audience's if I talk about this there
will be a reflexive say oh that's
because the Europeans had a superior you
know grasp of Science and Technology
then I try to point out this was a
result of stupidity this this is
something that that inadvertently and
with no foresight at all happened to
supply Europe with the capacity other
parts of the world didn't have because
Europe in its first 3,000 years a
vehicle use stuck to a really bad design
okay now let's take this notion of a
really bad design and go somewhere with
it
Oh
I kept talking about a team of oxen two
oxen of course you can put two more in
front of them and say it's four oxen but
your basic team is a pair of animals and
what hooks them together is a yoke in
laughin and you go one of the most
pregnant words in a new period in new
European languages because it refers to
hooking two things together so that a
man and a woman are hooked together in a
conjugal bond that ju-jee in there means
they're yoked together when you have
animals particularly oxen and horses
they were counted in ancient
indo-european languages by the yoke I
have so many yoke of oxen so many yoke
of horses for for property a you gyum
came to be regarded as as a an area of
land the area of land that could be
plowed in a single day by a yoke of two
oxen it's a word you know the notion of
yoking two things together is uh you
know pervades the culture
it has been related and here just let me
just mention a rather speculative theory
anyone who wants to follow it up there's
a Italian writer named Google wrote a
book called eel dualism oh very
interesting unfortunately as an Italian
his theory is that the the absorption
with the number two arises from a
conception basically a cosmological
conception that unity is - I haven't
talked about this in this crush how I
know I'm sorry about somebody - about
this recently that unity is - his
is what concrete example comes from the
languages of Indonesia and Malaysia and
related Austronesian languages and what
he observes and which which you learn
very readily if you if you take bahasa
melayu or bahasa indonesia is that the
word for one is literally 1/2 say Tonga
a two is unity that is the complete
thing but one is 1/2 the the way this
comes into English is that say Tonga
becomes the name of a cocktail called a
stinger you know say Tonga stinger sting
guy whatever and which is about half gin
and half something else fell the Brits
probably like be like half J and half
whiskey or something I don't know but he
said that the idea of unity being two
instead of one fits in with the concept
the cosmological concept of dualism in
which you have light and dark good and
evil male and female yin and yang that
everything has a complement that you you
you know you simply don't have
completion unless you have the two parts
of a complement any argues that this
goes back to Paleolithic times and that
you can find it throughout Eurasia and
North and South America the notion of
unity being being - in the indo-european
languages the ones that are spoken from
northern India across Iran and Europe
this has been studied with less of a
focus on cosmology but just mostly on
linguistics by a Dutch Sanskrit and Yong
Honda who has a short a quite
fascinating book called the numerals one
and two in a proto-indo-european and he
he raises this this question of do the
words in the indo-european languages
like English or Hindi or Persian or
Russian do the words originally the
words 1 & 2 mean 1/2 and the whole and
by looking at scores of different words
like twin and double and things like
that he concludes that that that there's
a very early linguistic stratum that
does indeed indicate that the
indo-european languages or the
proto-indo-european language for which
they all drive had this conception of
unity being two and one being one-half
so in the cosmogenic myth of the of the
earliest and europeans you have the
notion of the first person who was named
as usually manu and his twin whose name
is Hema and Yima is sacrificed and the
world is made out of his body but the
word you know Hema is there as twin this
shows up in in Roman history as Romulus
and Remus
because Remus can be traced back
phonological II to being a Latin variant
Lattin at a development of the word Hema
for for twin in Norse mythology you have
a giant Amir and the world is made out
of him so this is the argument that the
notion of completion being - is built
into the earliest stratum now whether
you go with Bianchi and you say this
stretches all the way from Ireland to
you know Tierra del Fuego cross Eurasia
and throughout the Americas or whether
you take the more restrictive view of
Honda and you look at the earliest in
the European languages and you and you
use the connection with Indonesian only
as a as a distant comparison rather than
part of the same phenomena if it doesn't
take away from them from the notion that
doubleness
Tunis can have a very powerful force now
if you go into East Asian culture
everyone recognizes this yin yang is no
common place if you get into Western
cultures or submitted cultures although
I point out that Cain and Abel make a
very nice pairing in this but if you get
into these Western cultures it's less
evident but one place where it becomes
evident is in the insistence on yoking
to animals to a vehicle
before anyone ever thought to hook up a
horse to a chariot and to say when
wheeled vehicles were still pulled by
oxen the people who were most associated
with early evidence for the use of
training of horses and of using chariots
and these are the Hittites who lived in
central Turkey and who produced the the
first text we have on the training and
use of horses and chariots their storm
God traveled in a chariot drawn by oxen
not by horses and it's very clear that
the association between a wheeled
vehicle drawn by two animals and a God
was prior to the invention of the war
chariot or the development of the notion
of the horse-drawn vehicle and in fact
throughout the indo-european culture is
not the Semitic you find lots of
evidence of the Gods riding in chariots
so the Sun is seen as a as a chariot
that travels through the heavens driven
pulled by the horses of Phoebus Apollo
the animals that pull the chariots are
not always cattle and not always horses
for example they can be geese because
after all if you're going to pull a
chariot through the heavens it would be
useful to know how to fly
the the early word for goose that
survives in German is honza and so when
you fly and Lufthansa in the air goose
you're kind of getting a little flavor
of this old notion of the the chariot
pulled by geese through the sky
maybe there's another meaning for Hausa
as well you know but I'm not going to
give you that one the so you have some
you had different gods
Thor's chariot is pulled by goats there
is a famous chariot race and a wedding
in early Indian mythology in which all
the gods have a chariot race and each
one is in a chariot drawn by a different
animal and which animal wins the race
it's the chariot drawn by donkeys and
then they say it exhausted the donkey so
much that even though they won the race
from then on they were weak and humble
animals but that preserves and you know
a much earlier notion of the donkey is a
sacred animal in and of itself I have
just finished writing a novel called the
one donkey solution that is based
entirely on the mythology of sacred
donkeys and how that might relate to
Israel Palestine negotiations or the
threat posed to Israel by the Iranians
and it is absolutely absurd novel but if
anybody wants it on a PDF file just
email me and let me know and you can
read the one donkey solution I thought
Eddie was ever going to publish it it
insults everybody
but I felt that when Avenida Zod came
here and I helped facilitate setting up
his talk at Columbia I played a role in
making him kind of a international star
now I'd like to play a role in
humiliating him on an international
basis but you know probably not going to
happen but I know so much about donkeys
I I just can't begin I wish I could I've
been doing it for the last year just
working on donkey stories anyway
not to digress the the association of
the yoked animals with the chariot with
the gods carries over into the role that
the horse chariot plays in the social
structure of the society that finally
develops it namely a Central Asian
society where it becomes a war vehicle
into European society at that time had
two castes of of people who were sort of
co-equal it had the Brahmins
who were the priests and it had the
Cassatt Reyes who are the Warriors the
King was always a kesariya there are two
other castes below them the vices and
the sudras but there are much below them
in the in the original form it's really
the the priests and the Warriors who are
at the top of society the warriors ride
in chariots and it becomes the the mark
of their class because they are like
gods so you have this strong association
of riding in a war chariot that makes
you a sort of semi-divine warrior figure
so now think about the Iliad there you
have Patroklos has been killed
there are funeral games so called in his
honor and the culminating one is the
chariot race and this is you know these
were not games these were very very
sacred things and the notion of the
chariot race being a sacred ceremony
carries on for hundreds of years in the
Hippodrome em in Istanbul and Hippodrome
elsewhere the Emperor and the religious
elite would would attend the chariot
races
I am absolutely certain that that NASCAR
is the contemporary expression of this
indo-european obsession with racing
vehicles it's another book will get
published out the so when you have
chariots that are buried in high status
graves and even when they're buried in
Xiang China where there is you know that
starts around 1750 BC the Shang Dynasty
in China as you know because you read
the chapters of carefully there's very
little evidence at that time that the
chariots were really used for warfare
they were status markers and their
status markers pretty much all the way
through there is a great question as to
whether chariots were ever very
effective in the battlefield except
against other chariots because you know
if the battlefield is bumpy the chariot
might turn over you have one chariot
driver one warrior two horses and a
vehicle five combat entities if any one
of them goes down the whole unit goes
down whereas if you put one man on a
horse you have to combat and entities
and you've more than doubled your combat
effectiveness the Roman
strategic writer would get iou's
explicitly in his chapter on chariots
talks about what a dumb thing would be
to have chariots because they depend
upon level terrain and they're just not
very efficient and overtime every
country that adopted the war chariot a
man in the war chariot fairly early the
people in Central Asia being the first
to abandon it and moved to to cavalry
however the the symbolic role of the war
chariot continued so that the Romans did
not have chariots but according to Livy
when the Roman King back in the very
early times when the Romans had actually
knows the Kings I guess it's the early
republic anyway when you had a consul of
who won victory he would be granted a
triumph a triumph was a ceremony in
which of the the the successful general
would march through Rome with his army
and with his captives and with his booty
and it would be a great public display
but the the general victorious general
was the only person who wrote on a
charity and he was painted Vermillion
from head to toe because that was the
color of the statue of Jupiter on the
Capitoline hill and he would be going
along carried on a chariot as the stat
as a god and running along beside him
there would be a slave who supposedly
would keep looking up and saying
remember thou art not a God
that what not a god so the association
of wheeled vehicles in God's is is as
close even to the extent that if you had
a ruling family that that had a claim to
be divine they might not be permitted to
ride on a horse
this is the Merovingians who ruled
France after the fall of the Roman
Empire had to you know they were divine
they were divine lineage of Kings they
weren't allowed to shave their beards
and they had to ride on wheeled vehicles
I figure France has about you know you
know five trees purrs you know no five
feet so that presumably mostly variant
Merovingian army spent most of the time
cutting on trees so the king could get
through on this wheeled vehicle but it's
this association of the wheeled vehicle
and this plays into the notion of these
high status women and at a later point
after the invention of the coach of
European monarchs riding in carriages
instead of riding on horseback the
you know this extends into into China
first under the Xiong and then it then
war chariots come along later and it's
one of the examples of the diffusion of
of practices across very broad distances
because this is a case where you can
pretty clearly show that it was borrowed
from from peoples who are much further
west in Central Asia but the fact that
you had the wheels of the Shang Dynasty
royal chariots being five feet in
diameter sort of indicates the degree to
which these additionally these are more
signs of a quasi divine status than
simply means of transportation or even
means of war and this relates to
something else I wanted to talk about
but I'll get into it more next week and
that is the beginning of writing because
in China the earliest writing that we
have that's verified I stress that
because there are theories that say that
Neolithic pottery has Potter's marks on
it that are sort of proto Chinese
writing but the earliest Chinese writing
that is verified and can be where words
can be identified and translated and so
on comes from the xiang period from 1750
BC onward for until about 1200 BC it
doesn't come from the entire period but
from a period about two or three hundred
years and it takes the form of what are
called oracle bones which are described
in your chapter in some detail but the
main thing is that the divination
used in the oracle bones had to be done
by by the emperor by the king because
you know if you you know you you can't
be an Oracle be a prophet via seer
without certain attributes and the
attribute for the Xiong ruler was that
he was the he was the Emperor so that he
could have assigned it to the you know
the court minister of cracking turtle
shells it had to be him in the same way
that in a semitic tradition only certain
people could be priests only certain
people could be prophets only someone
descended from David can be can be the
Messiah and this is something that you
get in other parts of the world it's
just that usually the attributes are by
lineage for learning or something that's
of high cultural but in the case of the
of the chariots it really is a
technological attribute that imparts to
the country is this spiritual authority
report the Brahmins do not ride in
chariots and in a in a sacrifice the
Kshatriya provides the animal but the
Brahman is the one who performs a
sacrifice and I've written about that in
the part that's been assigned to you
from my book on on animals but I'm going
to talk more about writing next week and
I'm also going to give you some readings
for next week of a cosmogenic character
how did the universe come into being in
the conception of of some different
peoples and I'll put up some sort of
thought questions
of course works as well you'll hear
about that
through course works